foreign
all right we are live on the world wide
web people I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report and it is Friday which
means it's time for another round table
panel Extravaganza all in celebration of
America on her upcoming
246th birthday she looks pretty good
despite what's going on with the people
in charge right now joining me today are
a senior fellow at the Manhattan
Institute Chris Ruffo host of The Young
Terror the young Heretics show Spencer
Clavin an opinion editor of Newsweek
Josh Hammer Chris Spencer Josh welcome
back to the Reuben report
thanks for having us back Dave all right
guys America on her 246th birthday July
4th just a couple days from now and you
may remember this we've got to show you
something right up top from last year on
July 4th it was very exciting because we
all saved 16 cents on our July 4th
barbecue look at this tweet from the
White House planning a cookout this year
catch up on the news according to the
Farm Bureau the cost of a Fourth of July
BBQ is down from last year it's a fact
you must heard hot dog the Biden
economic plan is working and that's
something we can all relish the cost of
a Fourth of July cookout in 2021 is down
16 cents for last year uh from last year
and then there was this video this is a
year ago I think today Peter Ducey who
is a rare journalist that I can say they
were a journalist without putting air
quotes he asked Jen saki about these
whopping savings okay on another subject
the official White House account tweeted
yesterday the cost of a Fourth of July
cookout is down 16 cents from last year
16 cents there has been a reduction in
some of the costs of key components of
the Fourth of July a Fourth of July
barbecue that was what the Tweet was
noting so does the White House think
that 16 cents off a barbecue has more of
an impact on people's lives than gas
being a dollar more this time not this
far I would say if you don't like hot
dogs you may not care of the reduction
of costs you don't have to like hot tubs
a reduction I will say that what we are
most focused on is the fact that we've
created now more than three million jobs
since the president took office that's
what we're focused on and continuing to
implement additional uh components of
his economic build back better agenda
so I'm a big fan of showing these old
throwback videos because I think we
forget how inept these people are we
forget about all the people that got
here even watching sake just now I
forgot what she was like after you know
we have our new press secretary who you
have to say she's a black lesbian every
time you bring her up Jean Karin Pierre
uh 16 cents Josh what do you do with
your 16 cents before we get to this year
and the price increase what did you do
with your extra 16 cents last year
Dave you know look I I mean maybe it
went just a little extra relish my
fourth of July hot dog or something but
I mean like you know to your point I
mean I I just had a flashback my mind
literally just now to that clip that
went viral a couple weeks ago of the new
as you say black lesbian press secretary
at the White House Billy you heard this
one she was literally flipping through
the binder about the baby formula
shortage it was like literally like
nails on a chalkboard silence I mean
this Administration just continues to
redefine incompetence each and every day
that ends in Y which obviously is all
seven days of the week I mean it's
hitting a new low basically every
weekend you know this stuff is just
crazy I'm not sure when they signed up
kind of Jewish dad humor to be writing
these kind of White House tweets I mean
like my my my you know my 65 year old
father could have written that tweet but
I'm not sure it's very presidential
catch up with the news people Spencer
um 16 cents I mean the for putting aside
again we're going to get to the increase
this year which is significantly more
than 16 cents but just the gall that
they had to do that like put that tweet
out there 16 cents as if that means
anything well it's it's the layers of
cringe for me right it's
to that point Chris do you think that
this stuff works on anyone do you think
that there was literally one person last
year I mean I really mean this do you
think one person saw that tweet and said
boy I saved 16 cents thank you Joe Biden
I I don't think so and uh if you kind of
pull back it's really interesting and
basic communication strategy you always
want to lead uh with the best news that
you have the strongest uh kind of brag
about what you've been up to and they
looked at the whole White House looked
around at the country and said all right
this is what we go with today this is
the best news that we can possibly come
up with some sort of artificial basket
of goods like rutabagas and something
obscure where they could say well the
price is actually down not up in
comparison to everything that you'd see
at the store if you would go today but
more seriously this administration's
kind of key Playbook is to suppress
reality with these false images so I
think very similarly to this you look at
the uh the guy with the high heels and
the dress and the bald head doing the
kind of pup Kinks uh taking over the
nuclear waste disposal and you say well
what is the substance the substances
that our nuclear energy program hasn't
advanced in decades but at least you get
the a bald pup Kink guy you know flexing
his heels in the White House photographs
and so they're trying to kind of replace
any substantive tangible good for actual
real life people with these fake images
whatever they may be uh day by day yeah
and that's a great point because you
know we're talking about Jean Curran
Pierre too and there was that image of
her a few weeks ago with Rachel Levine
and it's like they're there and it's
pride month and they're very happy and
we've got the first black lesbian in the
first trans whatever and it's like well
are you guys qualified at your jobs is
this pup person qualified to be a
nuclear I guess the pup guy does have
some pedigree if people qualified yeah
yeah he's at least somewhat qualified I
suppose anyway uh all of this leads us
to what's happening this year in the
world of reality and uh yeah you're not
uh saving 16 cents anymore take a look
we're less than a week away from
America's birthday on the celebration
menu we get together with the family and
have a barbecue burgers and hot dogs
corn on the cob a Choppers brace
yourselves because according to the
American Farm Bureau Federation Market
survey Americans will be spending on
average around 70 dollars for a 10
person July 4th menu up 17 compared to
last year there's some Shenanigans going
on economists explained the shenanigans
as inflation
we like showing uh local news every now
and again because it's such a Time Warp
isn't it I don't have a TV anymore but
when you see those clips and they get
the people outside and it's like there's
something oddly refreshing about it in
our Bizarro World these days so Spencer
we went from saving 16 cents very
exciting to prices going up 17 not 17
cents 17 will you be splitting one hot
dog
yeah I'll be carving it up into little
slivers and giving it out to the guests
at my party no I mean actually what I
like about that uh yeah that news clip
is how refreshing it is and you know a
sort of heartbreaking to see regular
Americans it's like oh right that's what
normal people look like you know and
they have
whoop I think we might have lost uh we
might have lost Spencer for just a
second Josh pick it up what are you
gonna do 17 higher costs right now
yeah I mean look I mean everywhere you
go Dave and the only need to be the one
to tell you you know I mean you're my
favorite
Floridian sorry Spencer back no
go ahead Josh we'll figure that out
sorry no I mean you're myself learning
here I mean like look the price of gas
at the pump here in Miami-Dade as you
know I mean I look at these numbers and
I'm like is this my phone number is this
my area code I mean I mean like what
what is going on here I mean it really
it really is crazy and obviously it's
not just the price of gas I mean like
you know I was at a restaurant just last
night actually I was out to dinner with
our friend Carol Marco at State and like
everything on the menu I mean it's just
like dramatically different than what
like I can just bear remember it being
just a few months ago I mean the sticker
price effect I think on the basic menu
every single day at this point is
already real so what this Administration
is doing with all these catchy videos I
mean it's just a constant exercise and
Chris made this point earlier it's just
a constant exercise and goal post
shifting they're just constantly trying
to shift the goal post to try to
establish the fact that they're not
quite as terrible as the median American
which we saw in these videos the media
American obviously recognized I think
just how bad it actually is right out
there Chris are you kind of happy that
they're messaging is this bad because
you know so many of the policies are bad
so at least they're messaging them
poorly and more and more people seem to
be waking up
and I'm obviously sad that the messaging
is bad because it reflects an underlying
reality of what they're doing to the
country which is bad but in the sense of
pure politics looking at their actual
communication strategy I think it's just
really an eye-opening thing to see
you've seen democrats for example even
this week really lighting their hair on
fire uh screaming and going into kind of
hysterical fits uh talking about packing
the courts and abolishing the Electoral
College and eliminating the filibuster
well at the same time they control the
house the Senate and the presidency all
of these things are a sign of in a
reflection of a deeper ineptitude on
behalf of the political left and for
that I am in some ways somewhat grateful
because they're giving us a lot of
openings to start planning the
counter-attack in 2022 and then the big
counter-attack in 2024. Spencer actually
why don't you bring us home on that
point now that we got you back that that
something does seem to be turning I
think it's becoming more obvious to the
average person their level of ineptitude
and whether it's intentional or just
complete incompetence so there's some
hope there right absolutely well yeah
the feds got to me earlier but now I'm
not icing
uh thanks for waiting I I do think you
know you will look at the reaction to
this Dobbs decision and you see people
not only who have no idea what the
actual substance of the question on the
table is what's been decided how our
system works we've been had their brains
essentially scooped out with a melon
baller but they're also they've become
these rage puppets of the regime you
know they've they've triggered now they
can they can sort of snap like dogs on
cue at their leashes and you see them
screaming and twerking and just
degrading themselves in public and you
think you know that's a that looks
miserable I wonder how that's working
out for you that you know that can't be
living your best life and I can't be how
the vast majority of Americans want to
see themselves want to think about their
country or or think about their future
and and so many people have been trapped
for so long feeling like there was no
way out for them except this kind of
democratic mad bacchanal and the crazier
that gets and the Freer we become on the
right to speak our minds to have fun
right to to actually just point to
reality and say regardless of your prior
political commitments like something's
not working here um it's a huge
opportunity we have to push this
Advantage we have to just this is not
the time to back down or squish out or
be afraid to talk about any of these you
know culture War issues because they're
winning issues and people are waiting to
be liberated from the sick and
pathological cycle that the Democrats
have them trapped in it's really sad to
look at and we have a way out Spencer
well said and you gave me a perfect
segue into the next segment because yes
I think people are sick of the gender
stuff I think people are sick of the
race stuff and the rest of it I think
people want to go back to just viewing
Americans As Americans and individuals
and being judged on their Merit and say
not their skin color there was this guy
a long time ago who didn't want his kids
to be judged on his skin color on their
skin color I always forget his name but
speaking of people who don't like that
there's this guy Mark Lamont Hill and
Chris you had a rather spectacular
incident with this guy so he he's a big
Progressive Lefty he's got a show on
some Network or something I want to
throw to this clip of you on his show
and the reason I'm doing this on our
fourth of July show is because your
defense of what really is American in
the face of sort of the accusations of
racism is just absolutely perfect
name something positive that you like
about being white
well sure I you know I'll I'll answer
with uh with a thing there there's a lot
of documents that are floating around
public schools that say things like uh
timeliness showing up on time is a white
supremacist value or a white Value white
dominant value things like rationality
things like the enlightenment things
like uh you know uh uh objectivity and
uh these are very strange things to be
ascribed to a racial identity my view is
that these are actually should be
ascribed to every individual human being
every individual human being regardless
of whatever racial category we impose on
them that doesn't answer the question
though
you're telling me you're making
strawment about things that are ascribed
to whiteness that you think are
wrongfully described to whiteness I'm
saying if whiteness isn't a negative
thing and there's something that you
actually and that whiteness actually
shouldn't be constructed as all negative
name something positive about being that
you believe is positive about being
white
again I don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
Blackness I think that's wrong I think
we should look at people as individuals
I think we should celebrate uh different
people's accomplishments I think of
myself as an individual human being with
my own capabilities and I would hope
that we could both judge each other as
individuals uh and uh come to common
values on that basis
fair enough
fair enough Chris I often say on the
show that when you hear something true
these days it's just so refreshing
because everything is just such layered
nonsense all the time but that clip uh
you know imagine if you had said the
reverse to him and that's what I think
people are fed up with and have had
enough with uh America individual it's
all pretty individualism it's pretty
good right
that's right and I think the the bait
and uh that he was trying to lay for me
was for me to buy into the same
framework that maybe he has bought into
reducing people to racial categories
pitting them against one another in this
kind of
Eternal conflict
um and look that's how the world worked
for most of its history and it's
actually a magical thing that we've been
able to transcend it as much as we have
I think we still have a way to go
um we need to kind of depolarize and
Rise Above some of these divisions in
this country but I think we can do it
and I think that we have done it and we
shouldn't let people like Mark Lamont
Hill drag us back down and whoever you
are if you are black white asian Latino
straight gay let's start to treat each
other equally and respectfully and give
each other a sense of dignity as
individuals because what we learned in
the 20th century just like the centuries
before is that when you provide people
with totalizing identity categories
things can get very ugly and very
destructive in a very quick manner yeah
you know I would say we don't have very
far to go actually we just have to start
ignoring these people I think we all got
there and then they Unearthed it again
we we don't really have to do much on
that Josh you're in Miami as I am in
Miami we live in one of the most
Multicultural cities in the United
States I hear as much Spanish as English
I've got a couple Honduran guys working
in my kitchen right now nobody cares
who's gay nobody cares what language you
speak as long as you can figure out a
way to communicate with each other it's
all good here in America these These are
the guys who are bringing it all back
yeah you know it's funny Oliver Weissman
uh who's an editor of The Spectator he
had an essay in City Journal Chris's
publication a few months ago it was
about the city of Miami and the title of
the essay was the least woke city in
America it's a very interesting essay I
would encourage the the viewers to go go
ahead and check it out and what he
basically says Dave is kind of what you
said here is that I view what's
happening here in Miami What's Happening
Here in our backyard what's happening
here kind of in Florida perhaps to go a
little further in general it really is
Ground Zero of a broader American
realignment and what you are
increasingly seeing is Hispanics to a
slight lesser extent blacks but really
kind of just working class middle income
people all across the country who have
just totally had it with the woke
nonsense they have just totally had it
with the imperious moralistic
high-handed nature of our purported
would-be woke superiors who refused A
countenance the possibility that their
opinion might not be gospel truth or
Moses descending from Sinai with the
tablets I mean it is really not that
difficult to understand here but you're
really seeing it play out to your point
right here in Miami I mean I will I live
walking distance from Little Havana you
walk over there you see Maga Trump 2020
Trump won signs literally everywhere you
go Joe Biden stuff nowhere to be found
you will see a lot of let's go Brandon
stuff though there is a lot of let's go
branded stuff here floating around in
Florida and our governor does refer to
him as Brandon uh Spencer it's like what
what else do we have to do I think
you're the youngest on the panel what
else do we have to do with the young
people to to completely get rid of these
ideas well thank god last time I was not
the youngest it turned out right right
and I was very disappointed in that uh
but yeah now I've retained my status and
you know look we're here for the 4th of
July
um it is this momentous occasion for
reflecting on the history of our country
and one of the things that fills me with
the most sorrow when I hear these clowns
get up and say things like you know
America is founded on systemic racism
there's racism in the DNA of the country
right is you know we've been through
this before at the cost of much blood
and treasure and you know when somebody
says America's founded on systemic
racism you know there is somebody that I
hear echoed in the background from the
history of our country and it's not
George Washington and it's not Abraham
Lincoln it's Stephen Douglas right the
famous opponent of Lincoln who got up
and said that this country was founded
on the white basis and he was advanced
an interpretation of the meaning of our
country and the meaning of our founding
documents and it was only by putting
forward the true interpretation of those
documents that Lincoln was able to stand
up and say no and one of the things that
he did is he appealed to the Declaration
this idea that all men are created equal
which we celebrate you know on this
weekend and he said most Americans you
know they may be indifferent to slavery
because it doesn't affect them they may
indeed in some cases feel they have to
hold slaves but in their hearts they
know what's true about life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness they know that
all men are created equal and they know
that the rest of this stuff that this
Douglas guy is saying is utter garbage
and as Chris was pointing out you know
that's not a given Americans are an
amazing people in this way we have you
know beaten into us by our history by
the suffering that our forebears had to
go through in order to win this precious
Nation we have a sense innately in us
that is taught to us from our Traditions
that all of this woke stuff is
regressive it's the most profoundly
primitive regression away from what this
country is supposed to be and you know
God help me for all that our Elites have
attempted to erase that from the public
view I still think that when they go out
into those parking lots and they talk to
those folks in those grocery stores I
hear the voice of America it doesn't
matter how old you are people are still
suspicious of this stuff and it's
obvious who's on the right side here
Chris what do you think the win actually
looks like like is the wind just
political like okay Republicans get this
big red wave we reverse a little or a
bunch a whole bunch of what's going on
in some of these states Etc et cetera or
is there something else that we should
be looking to as oh wow we really did
you know exercise wokism from the
mainstream and we really did defeat it
and get rid of it and it's out of the
schools Etc et cetera yeah I think you
have to make it so unappealing uh and
simultaneously allow people allow the
public to start speaking openly against
it and then you shift the incentive so
that uh there is no incentive to adopt
this kind of ideology wherever you might
be and you know one thing that I think
about especially on the fourth of July
is a television image from 2020 it was
in the middle of the pandemic first
round of lockdowns it was in a kind of
just on the tail end of the most
destructive BLM riots and I remember
seeing this Drone footage on local news
in Los Angeles not exactly a right-wing
Place uh and the government had said no
fireworks you can't do it it's banned
and yet they have this Drone footage of
the entire city Millions upon millions
of people the whole sky is lit up with
these mortar fireworks and it showed me
one thing one Americans still have the
spirit to rebel against unjust Authority
and also most Americans even in a deep
blue place like Los Angeles still love
this country we have to tap into that
sentiment telling people from all
different uh identity backgrounds and
all different geographical backgrounds
this is still a great country join US
participate with us and Vanquish this
evil ideology that has spread too far
Josh to that point since you're running
the the Newsweek op-ed page and we want
to give the devil is due there are
people that obviously believe completely
the reverse of everything that we're
saying here how do you go about managing
to say what voices should and shouldn't
be heard related to all of this oh look
I mean at a personal level you know I
oversee a team of five editors like four
deputies one of whom body Unger Sargon
has kind of made a bit of a name for
herself over the past year year and a
half it's kind of an outspoken anti-woke
liberal of sorts but yeah I mean we are
taught we are trying to do something
that now is counter-cultural and really
is kind of counter-historical given the
current moment which is trying to
actually kind of give all sides a fair
hearing so I kind of just go out there
and I you know I give it my all I mean
my column just out today actually you
know to your question Dave earlier what
do we do next is actually focusing
specifically and kind of the legal
judicial Arena which is kind of my area
of specialty in the aftermath of this
you know real string of consistent
Supreme Court victories where we go from
there but yeah I mean we'll platform any
of other people as well I I just want to
highlight one other thing though because
Spencer touched on you know Spencer's a
good Claire monster of course for for
invoking Abraham Lincoln onto his
birthday I'm born that's my favorite
figure in American history but to your
point Dave we really don't have to go
back very far you know I wrote a column
back when I when I was at the daily wire
a few years ago Lincoln really is the
seminal figure that we need to look to
on July 4th beginning because he really
did cherish the Declaration he referred
to it as the electric core that kind of
binds the generations you know the Dead
the living and the yet unborn and the
Declaration is is just a Vindication of
exactly what Chris has been fighting for
in his own work for the past two years
which is that we are all children in the
eyes of God we are all equal citing
Genesis one whatever your religion is
you can just look at that and just
observe the world you can deduce that by
pure reason we're all human beings it
doesn't matter what color you are what
skin you are whatever that is the
message I think of America and that's
what we should be celebrating this
weekend man and we are pinned as the
racists well said my friend and actually
you've also given me a perfect segue to
the third segment here because in
defense of the West and individualism
and everything else I thought there's no
one better that we could throw to than
Jordan Peterson and Jordan had a bit of
an odd week because currently he is
suspended on Twitter for uh saying
something about Ellen or Elliot page
whatever you want to call it uh her him
whatever and then which probably just
got me booted I had a good run though
you know I feel like uh getting booted
on the July 4th weekend is sort of right
um so I want to throw to a clip of
Jordan but not only did that happen that
he got suspended but he also announced a
massive partnership with the daily wire
but here's Jordan on individualism and
the West the fundamental assumptions of
Western Civilization are valid how about
that you know it's not
you think it's an accident oh here's how
you find out okay which countries do
people want to move away from hey not
ours which countries do people want to
move two hours guess what they work
better and it's not because we went
around the world stealing everything we
could get our hands on it's because we
got certain fundamental assumptions
right thank God for that after thousands
and thousands of years of trying and
because of that we've managed to
establish a set of civilizations that
are shining lights in the world we
actually value the individual right the
individual has intrinsic value in
Western societies do you know how long
it took people to formulate that as an
idea and how unlikely that idea is that
poor you you know useless powerless you
with all your damn faults you're
actually worth something you're worth
something to the point that the law has
to respect you God we don't want to
abandon that for some half-witted
collectivism which we're doing as
rapidly as possible because one of the
things that characterizes the radical
left types is they don't give a damn
about you as an individual or about
individuals at all
man every time I think I'm a halfway
decent broadcaster or a sort of maybe
okay guy to communicate some ideas you
just watch a little Jordan and it'll put
you in your place Spencer this is sort
of your specialty I mean man he got it
right there we have turned through a lot
of bad ideas a lot of Bloodshed and and
a lot of pain to get where we're at
right now and we could be on the
precipice of giving it away sure enough
well you know you talk about those
fundamental assumptions of Western
civilization and you know as much as I'm
a patriot as much as I am an American
who loves his country one of the things
that makes me love the country so deeply
is that those fundamental assumptions in
the Declaration represent the jewel you
know the fruit of hundreds and hundreds
of years of Western striving and thought
you know the idea that all men are
created equal that they are endowed by
their creator with the inalienable
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness when the Declaration says
that the you know these truths are
self-evident people think that means
that they just fall from the sky oh it's
just common sense you know every
everybody thinks this but this is not
true it's not the case as Peterson is
pointing out there you know this is a
rare thing and it took a long time to
figure it out good civilizations high
and mighty civilizations in the past did
not believe this Sparta left babies to
die if they weren't strong enough you
know Aztec human sacrifice very much a
thing and even still today you've had
you've seen people in China under the
one child policy just abandoning babies
that that were unwanted that didn't fit
the needs of the state that were
economically inconvenient the human
heart man is full of evil and to guard
against that we need these fundamental
truths they're incredibly precious and
they we can never take them for granted
we have to understand that they come as
a kind of Island you know in a sea a
howling Wasteland of of human darkness
and to protect that you know against the
folks who are now as you say you know
bringing up exactly the same
Alternatives they present themselves as
charging forth into this bright glorious
new future they're just pagans I mean
you look at what's happening with with
Dobbs you know now there are going to be
states that will you know politicians
that will stand there and advocate for
babies to be aborted like up to two
weeks after birth you know I'm I'm not
even exaggerating I read articles in in
journals of of medical ethics and
philosophy of science that argue for
things called something called
post-birth abortion otherwise known as
infanticide and you know you think you
look at this and you think it's some
sort of shocking horror it's not it's
just the state of the human heart
without the protections that we
enshrined in our declaration and our
Constitution and you know what like we
get into this defensive Crouch sometimes
because they call us racist they call us
nasty and we just try to fight for the
bare minimum oh we're not racist we're
not nasty we're okay that's not enough
we're good man we're the best we're the
best that's ever been and we ought to
preserve this country because it's worth
it
not bad not bad dude you can come back
great all right Chris is the point is
the real point that that Spencer's
making there that nothing is
self-evident anymore that the things
that you're always fighting with people
about and trying to expose at at Disney
or at our schools that boys are not
girls that uh there is a difference
between being uh racist and non-racist
all of this stuff we don't take anything
for for obvious anymore there's nothing
real anymore
yeah that's right and we shouldn't take
anything for granted you've seen it just
even with the economy in very simple
kitchen table terms uh the economy
doesn't run itself it's actually an
incredible accomplishment to have clean
water plentiful electricity a large
comfortable home a car or maybe two cars
in the garage these are not natural
conditions these only exist in a very
tiny sliver of human history for a very
tiny sliver of human beings and it was
all invented and sustained here and so
everything from our system of government
to our economic way of life to our faith
and traditions these things need to be
fought for and renewed and I think in
some ways what makes me optimistic about
these fights that we're having like with
Mark Lamont Hill or with ibram candy or
with uh the kind of crazy gender people
is that we're returning to the
fundamental questions and I think if we
can re-answer these fundamental
questions which we've really not had to
answer in recent years because we've
taken them for granted we can maybe get
to that point of renewing uh those more
fundamental pillars of our society and
so that's really the task that we have
up for us today we're not debating about
20 versus 28 tax rates we're not
debating those technical terms we have
to go to the philosophical roots of our
situation our condition our country and
I think that we have to have good
answers just like Jordan Peterson does
in order to win
uh Josh I feel like you love that answer
right there like whoa let's actually
confront things let's know history and
let's let's have this out
I love both of these past answers from
my two friends Spencer and Chris me
Spencer after your answer there I Dave I
almost kind of jumped off after
Spencer's answer there and I tried to
pump some Toby Keith Courtesy of the Red
White and Blue or something like that
um no this is this is great stuff look I
mean Dave my entire kind of public
facing like role in this broader center
right political constellation that all
of us inhabit is basically to encourage
conservatives to do exactly what Spencer
and Chris and myself are all saying on
this panel which is do not be content
with a defensive posture do not be
content with playing defense neutrality
is not ultimately the goal I wrote this
directly in my column in Newsweek today
neutrality is is an uninspiring goal for
a political movement so the actual goal
is Victory the actual goal is to subdue
our opponents when our opponents are
people like Ibraham X candy critical
race theaters when they are people that
are trying to chemically castrate
children those people can roughly be
described as domestic enemies those are
our political foes and we have to be
willing to just assert that they are
going to call us racist sex is bigger
homophobes whatever you know as Andrew
you Breitbart once said walk towards the
fire embrace it just deal with it I mean
or else just don't be in this fight
obviously but there is no point in just
being in a weak position just pleading
tolerance tolerance those days are so
over maybe you will buy yourself like
one more day of Charity from The New
York Times editorial board if you plea
for help but
the forward way that we actually make
progress in this country again is not to
pursue kind of some faux neutral High
Ground that will actually never be
attainable is to actually chart out what
a vision of victory in the culture War
actually looks like
All-Star panel today absolute All-Star
panel I'll give you guys each one more
uh thought on
July 4th America maybe what you're
eating what you're doing where your
light and illegal fireworks etc etc
Chris you first
yeah I just encourage everyone to take
this time to spend it with your family
spend it with your neighbors at the end
of the day uh our lives are not
abstractions they're very particular the
people that we spend our time with the
place where we live so don't forget that
uh log off uh for the weekend maybe and
spend time with the people that really
matter to you
Spencer I have no doubt you will be at
the many uh breweries of Nashville I
will be taking a tour in fact of the
breweries of Nashville I know you guys
are Miami supremacists and I respect
that as we were discussing before the
show the fomo is real I see you guys
having those parties out there and you
know I wish I could come join but we
have a lot of good stuff out here in the
great state of Tennessee and I think
what Chris is saying is absolutely right
your neighbors are not you know some
these sort of identity categories that
the left and the media have tried to
shove them into you've the you know the
whole apparatus of our politics and of
our uh mainstream media basically exists
to erase the human individual from view
the neighbor that's right across the
street and what does Jesus say right
love thy neighbor as thyself there's a
reason that he puts a human person
almost in the place of God you love God
and love your neighbor right that the
reason for that is that it breaks down
all of this garbage and that's part of
what this country is about too you went
you may find that there's someone pretty
persuadable if you get out and you know
grill with them in your backyard and and
have a conversation
um and you know and God bless it God
bless this bless this country for uh
making that possible happy Fourth of
July Josh I remember very vividly last
year when I still lived in LA and we had
a little July 4th party thinking man I
live in a place that's so out of whack
with what with my beliefs and obviously
that had been happening for quite some
time now I'm in Florida there are
American flags everywhere there are
alligator Flags everywhere everyone's
free and happy here so I guess I could
just take it easy this year huh
well I would encourage you to take it
easy but you know I would also encourage
the viewers of this program I mean look
this is July 4th weekend it's a 246
anniversary obviously of the Declaration
of Independence this is a time I think
just worth contemplating a little bit
that America is fundamentally good I
mean not not to get like all like
pre-tron and soapbox but to get a preach
on a soapbox for a little bit America is
a fundamentally just Enterprise in
Republican self-government among men it
is the most just modern government that
has ever been instituted in the modern
history of political philosophy in the
in the modern history of kind of
tangible day-to-day governance it is
fundamentally worth defending against
the world totalitarians who want to burn
this thing down so as you guys but one
thing that I think the viewers could do
it's a little tripe I'll say it anyway I
would encourage everyone to just read
the Declaration of Independence I mean
that seems like a pretty logical thing
to do on July 4th weekend and it's very
difficult to kind of come away from that
very poetic and magisterial document and
conclude that this is anything other
than a fundamentally just country that
is worth defending until the day we die
well guys enjoy your Burgers enjoy enjoy
your dogs and your fireworks and all
that good stuff I'm gonna finish up for
a couple minutes have a good weekend and
I'll talk to you guys soon
thanks Dave
all right people I think we hit the
right tone what do you guys think here
in studio did we hit the right tone for
July 4th we did it we did it all right
very good uh that's it I don't know that
I need to add anything else other than
uh celebrate this great country even if
you don't live in this great country
even if you're watching this and you've
never visited this great country
246 years and does it sometimes feel
like we're about to give it away it does
but there are so many markers as we just
spent the last half hour talking about
there are so many markers that good
things are happening that sanity and
Clarity will prevail that freedom is
good individualism is good that states
rights and self-government are good and
I think we can get there I really do so
I hope you will enjoy your hot dogs I
hope you'll enjoy your Burgers your
fireworks and whatever else you do on
this July 4th spend a little less time
online maybe that's my challenge to you
and uh and we're off obviously for
Monday for the three-day weekend so
we'll be back on Tuesday thanks
everybody